i've seen such bizarre
um legal issues over the last few years
i mean you know since i've been doing
this and people bring this all to my
attention they send me articles and
videos and clips and stuff there is one
prominent one that stands out
a couple years ago there was a guy in
texas i think
and during the divorce
his wife wanted to
transition the child from a boy to a
girl and put him on
hormone blockers and get him on estrogen
and
um i don't know his name is peter let's
say and she would call him you know pam
when the child was at her house
and he lost the battle and she ended up
winning um
winning the case i think he even lost it
in supreme court if i'm not mistaken i'm
i'm not sure if you know about this one
but
she ended up
you know successfully being able to be
the primary caregiver and transition the
child from a boy to a girl and his
argument was like look here's all the
evidence at my house he's playing with
race cars and he dresses up as a boy and
he wants me to call him peter and it's
like i don't know what's going on over
there but this is but this is insane
like this is my child what are you doing
and the
courts like took that right away from
they turned peter into pam yeah
yeah
those are difficult cases when there are
those kind of divisions between yeah
i mean you don't have a crystal ball i
mean you have no idea what you're going
to be up against when you get divorced
chris's follow-up question or statement
says she's on video armed burglarizing
my home after she left district attorney
would not prosecute because no jury
would convict her in california
well you know
it's it's really remarkable how much bad
behavior just gets ignored by family law
courts and and they don't refer it to
criminal courts when they should is it
on both sides is it men and women or is
it fairly equal
i think there's bad behavior on both
sides i don't know if there are any
statistics about uh about you know what
the division is but um
you know sometimes people say oh well
you know if if someone lies in domestic
relations
they're guilty of perjury you know
that's a criminal offense well
we asked our local
district attorney when was the last time
anyone was prosecuted for
um perjury in a domestic relations case
and they sort of laughed at us they said
everyone assumes that everyone lies in
domestic relations cases and so
they've never prosecuted anyone for that
and so there's no quality control
there's no and
you know um
people complain about the fact that uh
that the parents lie in court but then
they don't there are no sanctions for
lying so
of course
if there's no consequences to the
deception then of course they're going
to do it right especially if they're
rewarded
right financial incentives or control of
the children of course they're gonna lie
i mean you have to like you have to see
the code in the matrix guy like guys
like there's there's there's the entire
system
and i'm gonna come off as like a mgtow
here right now but the entire system is
rigged against you if you're a guy the
line that my lawyer gave me when i told
him that i wanted out was you're not
going to go to court and i said to him
why and he said because you have the
penis and you're going to lose right all
right
how does this work you know break it
down for me and after two and a half
hour call it was like i basically just
like i just looked at the phone and i
was like i'm [ __ ]
i i didn't know what to do with all that
information but
that's why i've got dawn on here for you
that's why we're showing you what the
better states are versus the worst
states you can at least
it's a slaughterhouse uh you can at
least if you're going to do it march
into it with your eyes wide open and
hopefully make some better decisions and
choices what else you got for us don
well you know one of the things you want
to talk about is what people can do yeah
and i do want to underscore that you
know
i've always told fathers going through
this that you have three jobs here and
you have to keep
all three jobs in mind but you have to
keep the priority ranking in order the
first job is to be the best parent you
can be to your children within whatever
constraints the courts have imposed on
you so
if it's an unjustified requirement the
visitation be supervised still that's
not your kid's fault and you know you
you be the best dad you can't can to
your kids um even if the constraints are
really unfair don't let the injury
that's been done to you bleed over into
the way you're relating to your children
that's the first job the second job but
it's ranked after the first job is
to work as hard as you can to get the
arrangement with your children to be as
good as possible
and you know that's what uh what what
the
previous questioner said about you know
spending three years and 120 000 you
know that was working to get the best
outcome
that's vitally important but
don't be working on briefs and things
like that when you got your kids with
you and you could be out you know
throwing the baseball with your kids or
something like that
um
if you're if you're deprived of
parenting time you've got plenty of time
to focus on on your case
when the kids aren't around
the third job and this is the one that
so many
fathers forget
is
to change the system so this doesn't
keep on happening to people right
and
you know those of us who didn't get
broken by the system but see how flawed
the system is
ought to be working to change the system
and so one thing you can do this i'm not
this doesn't solve your case but it
might solve your children's case later
on you know if they're unfortunate
enough to go through the divorce system
um is to work to change the system but
there are things you can do to put
yourself in the best position you can be
in when you divorce and um i always tell
people it's like
you're playing football on a slanted
football field
that's what bias is it's a slam there's
a bias against fathers it's it's well
known it's demonstrable
i had attorneys say to me
i like to represent mothers because i
like to win but i like to represent
fathers because i like to get paid um so
there there is a bias but that means
there's a slant doesn't mean you can't
win it means you have to work harder and
smarter by the way it doesn't also mean
it also doesn't mean that if you do work
hard and smart you're guaranteed to win
i'm not suggesting that but you can
increase your chances of getting the
best outcome for you and your children
by working hard and working smart and
one of the things that's important to do
is to not let your emotions control you
especially in court
when when women are confronted with an
injustice with a threat to their most
precious relationship they're likely to
cry
and that evokes feelings of sympathy
in male judges in female judges right
if a man cries
it often evokes concern about whether
this guy's stable or not
the way that many men respond to threats
to
a relationship that they value is with
anger
and anger is counterproductive
in the court system yeah you really got
to cool your jets and stuff because you
look like oh maybe you're dangerous
maybe this guy isn't safe et cetera so
you got to keep a cool head you got to
let the facts do the heavy lifting
you've got to lead with what's best for
your children and not whether you're
being victimized or not you've got to
say look you know
i love my children i'm
i'm involved with my children my
children need me to be involved with
them and not to be a weekend visitor
but you need to provide the evidence for
that and it i mean
i guess this is obvious in a way but
i've seen so many fathers either
fall into the trap of getting angry and
yelling at court or
or not really focusing on making their
argument in terms of what's best for the
children i should say um you know i
wrote a paper in 1999 that argued that
parental rights were fundamental
constitutional rights in the u.s
and
that
family law courts routinely violate
those fundamental constitutional rights
and i have often had parents come to me
and say you know i would like you to
write a brief supporting this in my
court case or i'd like you to testify
and i tell them
um
i absolutely believe every word i wrote
in that paper but that's not the
argument that wins in
family law cases going in there and
arguing i have a right to this and how
dare you challenge these rights that
doesn't win
and your first job is to try to win the
best outcome you can for your kids and
what that means is showing the court
that this is best for your kids to have
people parenting
don't mean you don't have that right
just that's not the leading argument are
there any other um things that men
should contemplate before they get
married or
things that they should contemplate as
they're perhaps like would it make sense
let's say if a
marriage is on the rocks
and you live in a difficult state to
move the family to a father friendly
state it might that's a heavy lift to do
that um and with no guarantee of success
you'd have to establish residency in the
state i think it varies by states but
jeffrey residency probably six months in
the state uh to do that so it wouldn't
be as if a quick move would do it um
sometimes people talk about prenups
prenups can apply to to the division of
property and to other things like
alimony and stuff but they absolutely
don't apply to custody there won't
courts won't even consider there are
people who have written prenups you know
should the marriage break up we will
both retain custody
courts won't even look at that i know
that the american legal system is
slightly different from the canadian one
but we have a concept here uh a concept
here called fraudulent conveyance
and
what that what that really just means is
um
[Music]
you know if you if you took a hundred
grand worth of credit on your credit
cards
and uh you transferred the title of your
house into your wife's name as you're
racking up the debt with the intention
of never to never paying it and filing
for bankruptcy then uh
then a court could basically turn back
the clock on that change of the title
and put it back in your name and then
the creditor could sue you and take like
is there such a thing as fraudulent
conveyance in the uh united states you
know i don't know but i think there is
um
i believe
what else would would guys want to
contemplate as they're going through
this process so they can minimize the um
you know the damage to their kids uh you
know minimize the damage their wealth
you know things like that
so um
one thing that is counterproductive is
to try to hide assets
because
those are usually discovered and you've
lost credibility with the court
i think excuse me
i think that
it's um
mostly important really to be as
involved the father as you can be
consistent with you know providing so
forth for your family and then to be
able to show that to the to the court
um
although i've had attorneys say to me
that there are a number of factors in
deciding any case you know there's the
statute and there's case law and there
are the facts of the case and and
there's the decision maker the judge or
the magistrate in the case and the most
important is the judge or magistrate
because they have their own biases
i've seen
gender biases work against mothers as
well i've seen usually older male judges
who say well
dad's remarried and his wife is going to
stay at home his new wife is going to
stay at home and i think kids should
have a stay-at-home mom so i'm going to
give custody to dad because mom has to
work down they're set separated she's
not uh she's not remarried so forth um
and so mom suddenly gets cut out because
stuff doesn't happen very often but i've
seen that kind of bias as well
um
so that's interesting yeah um
something else i
wanted to say is a strategy here
first of all you know if you can avoid
court avoid it
um if there's
sometimes people talk about how you know
it takes two to tango but it only takes
one to drag the other person out onto
the dance floor right um so
uh but but if you can
um
convince
the other parent that you're going to
spend
enormous
sums of money
to battle this out in court and it would
be much better to mediate these issues
than do that and if you can mediate a
bunch of issues and only have a few that
you have to go to court that'll cut down
the expenses as well
so that's another mediation
uh
don tony's got a note there can you talk
a bit about the structure of the title
ibd program and how it drives government
incentives to stop share parenting
um i wish i could say it's a simple
story but it's rather complicated um the
uh
the federal government reimburses the
states for
66 percent for two-thirds of their
administrative costs in running a child
support um system
that's not a windfall to the state it's
but it compensates them for two-thirds
of this of this the state doesn't make
money from that
um
i've heard fathers complain
that
the
title 4d thing
encourages states to
to have high child support obligations
i think that's actually true but the
story is more complicated than most
fathers realize
there are
five incentive
factors that the federal government uses
to reward states for doing things it's
trying to encourage them to do
several of those don't have anything to
do with the size of a child support
award so for example one of the factors
is
the percent of cases in which paternity
is identified another factor is the
percent of cases in which a child
support order is issued that then
doesn't have anything to do with the
amount of the child support one of the
factors is
the
program efficiency
and program efficiency is measured
by the
quantity of
child support collected and distributed
divided by the administrative cost well
if you collect more child support from
each obligor
the amount of money you collect goes up
but the administrative cost doesn't
because it doesn't cost any more to
enforce a child score obligation for you
know
uh 500 a month as it does to 300 a month
so that does encourage states to have
larger child support obligations
but the main driving factor is this
how much of this incentive money the
state gets
depends upon a base amount that the
child support system produces and that
is based directly on how much child
support they collect
so for example
in 2019
california
collected
4 billion dollars in child support now
california is one it's the biggest state
by populations the biggest economy in in
the country
it's much higher than most other states
but it's not higher than texas
texas's base was 7.2 billion dollars
it's a smaller state in population it's
smaller
in its economy but it had higher child
support collections and what that means
is that
even if texas and california are doing
equally well in all these performance
measures
texas will get about twice as much
federal subsidy dollars as california
will
and so that is an encouragement for
states to set their child score
obligations higher
um and to collect more child support
okay i got some people waiting to hop in
and ask some questions um where do you
see this going in the next 10 15 20
years like do you see
this improving for fathers
like what's it what's the trend
i certainly think so um you know i said
that uh um it's frustrating for people
in this movement because that you know
there are many people that just give up
and they feel like they're hitting their
head against a brick wall and nothing's
happening but
um
as i said earlier
um the winds are in constant but they're
blowing only in one direction i mean the
changes have all been improvements
and we have now uh pending child support
i'm sorry pending
shared parenting legislation there in 23
different states there are 40 different
bills and there will be new ones
introduced in this legislative session
that many states are going into right
now
many of those uh are to establish a
legal presumption of 50 50 parenting
time we've had near misses in a number
of states in florida
they passed equal shared parenting
legislation pretty strongly in both
chambers of the legislature but then the
governor
vetoed it in missouri
um they we had equal shared parenting
legislation pass overwhelmingly in the
house and then it got held up on the
senate floor
because really of a
political pissing match between two
senators it had really nothing to do
with the merits of the bill but one of
them was just
you know not going to let the other one
move any legislation so we've had a
number of near misses and you know near
misses are frustrating but they indicate
that you know a hit might be coming soon
i think there are going to be a number
of states i hope ohio is one of them
that pass equal shared parenting
legislation in the next
in the next few years and i think this
is something that will snowball
because you know
they're actually there's a generational
aspect here we have overwhelming support
by for shared parenting uh
across the uh uh age groups but
you talk to younger people and their
view is duh
of course that's the way you're you know
you should do it um because you know the
patterns of parenting have changed you
know
we may have never really been in the
ozzie and harriet father knows best
world that might have always been a bit
of an exaggeration of the situation but
most families are dual income families
and in two-thirds of i'm sorry one-third
of dual income families the mother earns
more than the father
and so you know
women have careers
and men are taking on more of the
hands-on care of children and
and everyone is just
most people are just coming to see well
you know this is the way separated
parenting should happen so i really
think it is going to change
um can't say when it's going to change
in any any given state because these
idiosyncratic things pop up and block it
but
there is a distinct direction to the
movement let me ask you a quick question
before i pull these guys in um
i'm i'm doing some consulting right now
on a new startup business and
one of the recommendations that we were
tossing around was
taking a um taking out a small
percentage of the profits in the
business towards a social cause
and
i was going to recommend you know
something that that advances or furthers
the plight of fathers fighting to try to
get custody of their kids is there a is
there a non-profit is there an
organization that
that that stands out as one of the best
ones out there
well
we think national appearance
organization is a great organization we
have a number of corporations that have
some usually with matching funds from uh
because we have a uh
a a a supporter who uh who contributes
to npo and then their corporation
matches it and we have a number of uh
of companies that have made
contributions to npo and some family
foundations that have done so as well um
in canada i i know there are some
organizations and i'm sorry i'm not i'm
sorry it's actually a us organization so
so it would be in the united states yeah
so um
you know
we think and i don't think this is just
uh institutional bias on my part we
think that national parents organization
is the
largest and most effective shared
parenting organization
um in the country
we were directly responsible for the
great success in kentucky which has
served as a model for other legislation
and we worked with the state
organization in arkansas
working with some state organizations in
other
states
connecticut i'm sorry
and
wisconsin as well
um
and and one thing i've i
one thing that's given me a real hope of
change is that the various shared
parenting organizations are
working in greater
coordination than they had in the past
there used to be
much more conflict between organizations
about which organization you know gets
credit for something or and and there
were times when one organization would
fight against legislation good
legislation from a different
organization
um
that seems to me too to have gone and
people are now recognizing that
what matters is getting the legislation
passed
you